Os voy a hacer una pregunta ¿Qué pasaría
si un día Ronald Reagan resucitara de la
tumba y se encontrara con Donald Trump? ¿Se
harían amigos o no? ¿Tendrían las mismas
ideas? ¿Los mismos valores? Os puede parecer
una pregunta un poco tonta, pero creedme,
no lo es.
Veréis, tanto Ronald Reagan como Donald Trump
están considerados como iconos de la derecha
estadounidense ¿Verdad? Los dos son algo
así como el hombre del saco del la izquierda
y, bueno, los dos han hecho una carrera en
el mundo del cine o la televisión.
Sin embargo, aquí es donde terminan los parecidos.
La tarea de Reagan no era otra que sacar el
paÌs de una de las mayores crisis económicas
de su historia. Y para eso inició la llamada
revolución conservadora.
Una doctrina económica basada en bajar los
impuestos, reducir el gasto público y las
regulaciones.
A Reagan le gustaba el capitalismo y el libre
mercado más que a un tonto un lapicero. Y
en la parte personal, Reagan aparecía como
un hombre sencillo, humilde y campechano.
Algo asÌ como una figura paternal para todos
los estadounidenses. Un hombre de profundas
convicciones morales.
Donald Trump es todo lo contrario. Si algo
le gusta a este hombre es presumir de sus
millones de dólares, el lujo y una esposa
que podría ser su nieta.
Es otras palabras, que si Reagan era el padre
de la nación, Trump es el tío. El clásico
tío que todavía vive en un apartamento de
soltero, tiene una cuenta en TINDER y se emborracha
en la cena de nochebuena.
¿Y qué me decís de las ideas políticas?
Trump no es precisamente el mejor amigo del
libre mercado ni del gobierno limitado ¡Todo
lo contrario!
Si algo le gusta a este hombre es poner barreras
al comercio y proteger la economía del mercado
exterior. Al menos en teoría, la política
de Trump sería lo opuesto a los valores tradicionales
del Partido Republicano.
En otras palabras, que este partido está
pasando por una de sus mayores batallas ideológicas.
Por un lado, tenemos a esos republicanos que
defienden los impuestos bajos, el gobierno
limitado y los valores conservadores.
Y por el otro, tenemos a esos republicanos
que se acuestan con actrices de cine para
adultos, ponen aranceles al comercio internacional
y son amigos de Vladimir Putin.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Quién está ganando
esta batalla? Pues creo que ya os podéis
imaginar la respuesta.
Hay una oleada de republicanos que están
dejando el Congreso.
Con tantas diferencias ideológicas, hay toda
una generación de políticos republicanos
de la vieja escuela que están dejando el
Parlamento ¿Queréis un ejemplo? Pues quedaos
con este nombre: PAUL RYAN.
Paul Ryan era el portavoz de los republicanos
en el Congreso. Durante años, este hombre
se convirtió en guardián de las esencias
republicanas.
Quería reducir el gasto público y defendía
un gobierno muy pequeño y el libre mercado
sin restricciones.
Pues bien, Paul Ryan ya
ha dicho que no se va a presentar a las elecciones
legislativas.
Y muchos compañeros de partido están haciendo
lo mismo.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no es
todo!
El problema no son los que salen sino los
que entran. Y aquí tenéis el ejemplo de
ALABAMA.
El candidato al senado que apoyaba Trump,
Roy Moore, fue acusado de abuso de menores
durante la campaña electoral.
Después de este escándalo, los republicanos
perdieron en Alabama por primera vez en décadas.
Pero lo más sorprendente de todo es el hecho
de que un presidente republicano apoyara a
un supuesto depredador sexual ¿Os imagináis
algo asÌ hace solo 5 años? Como es lógico,
este escándalo en Alabama salió en todos
los periódicos nacionales y salpicó de lleno
a la Casa Blanca.
Y os preguntaréis ¿QuÈ hizo Donald Trump
para solventar esta crisis de comunicación?
°Exacto! ¡Nada! ¡No hicieron nada!
Y eso explica que ahora mismo haya tantos
candidatos republicanos que están cayendo
en las encuestas a pesar de presentarse en
estados tradicionalmente conservadores.
¿Pero todo esto, que significa para la Casa
Blanca?
Pues bien, como sabéis, este año hay elecciones
legislativas.
Las llamadas Midterms, donde se eligen a los
miembros del Congreso y a buena parte de los
miembros del Senado.
En Estados Unidos, el presidente, es decir,
el poder ejecutivo, se vota en unas elecciones
y el poder legislativo se vota en otras elecciones
totalmente distintas.
Eso explica que, por ejemplo, aunque Obama
fuera un presidente demócrata, la mayorÌa
en las cámaras legislativas fuera republicana.
Pues bien, en este caso, según muestran las
encuestas, es bastante probable que la mayor
parte de los candidatos republicanos pierdan.
Es decir, que Donald Trump va a tener bastantes
problemas para poder sacar cualquier ley con
un parlamento y un senado en su contra.
Pero la pregunta, la auténtica pregunta es:
¿Cómo ha llegado el Partido Republicano
hasta este punto? ¿Cómo hemos pasado del
Reaganismo al Trumpismo en tan poco tiempo?
¿Puede un partido cambiar de principios tan
rápido? Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
LA REVOLUCIÓN REAGAN
Seguro que muchos no lo sabéis pero Ronald
Reagan empezó su carrera polÌtica en el
Partido Demócrata. Tal cual como lo oÌs.
Sin embargo, en el año 1962, cambió de ideas
y de partido.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque el Partido
Republicano que se encontró Ronald Reagan
era muy distinto al que todos conocemos!
Según Reagan, los republicanos habían terminado
comprando casi todos los principios de los
demócratas. Y, seamos honestos, en parte
tenÌa bastante razón.
Si lleváis tiempo suscritos a VisualPolitik,
ya sabÈis que me encanta hablar de HEGEMONÕA
CULTURAL. De hecho, tengo un libro escrito
sobre este tema.
La hegemonÌa cultural es un concepto muy
marxista y a la vez muy útil para entender
la política. Básicamente, consiste son todos
esos valores que crea la élite dominante
para justificar su relación de poder.
Es un consenso que comparten prácticamente
todos los actores polÌticos, incluido el
partido de la oposición.
Pues bien, en aquella época, en los años
60, ese consenso era el estado del bienestar
y la necesidad de un control del estado sobre
la economÌa.
De hecho, tanto Nixon como Eisenhower, que
eran presidentes republicanos, pasaron por
la Casa Blanca sin apenas tocar la economía.
Y como os podéis imaginar, Reagan no era
precisamente un fan de esta hegemonÌa política.
Esto que vais a oir es un fragmento del discurso
"Tiempo de decidir". Los que seáis muy forofos
de la política estadounidense lo conocerÈis
seguro.
Ninguna nación en la historia ha sobrevivido
a una presión fiscal que alcance un tercio
de los ingresos nacionales.
Y aquÌ viene la parte interesante: la hegemonÌa
cultural es algo que se puede cambiar ¿Cómo?
Pues bien, cuando todos esos valores y esas
doctrinas ya no sirven para solucionar una
crisis, la gente pierde la fe en el sistema.
Y eso es, exactamente, lo que pasó en los
años 70, cuando Estados Unidos se enfrentó
a una de sus mayores crisis económicas.
Y esta crisis fue la ventana de oportunidad
para que Ronald Reagan pudiera reinventar
el Partido Republicano y crear un nuevo corpus
ideológico que es lo que ahora llamamos conservadurismo.
En otras palabras, Reagan creó su propia
ideología.
Y ahora os preguntaréis ¿Cómo se puede
crear una ideología? ¿Cómo se crea un discurso
político de la nada, que tenga sentido, y
que te permita ganar elecciones?
Pues muy sencillo. Reagan se dirigió a todos
esos grupos que, de alguna forma, se sentÌan
apartados por el mainstream político. Se
dirigió a la derecha religiosa por un lado.
Se dirigió a los militares por el otro.
Y finalmente, se dirigió a todos aquellos
que querían impuestos más bajos. Después,
reunió a todos estos grupos bajo un mismo
concepto, que es lo que llamamos el SIGNIFICANTE
VACÍO.
Un significante vacío es una palabra con
un significado muy genérico. Para que nos
entendamos, el significante vacío es algo
así como una letra de Heroes del Silencio
¿Alguien sabe lo que significa? No.
Y precisamente por eso, todos proyectamos
el significado que queremos que tenga. Para
algunos, Maldito Duende puede ser una canción
de amor, para otros, una canción protesta.
Pues bien, en el caso de Ronald Reagan, el
significante vacÌo era la LIBERTAD ¿Y qué
es la libertad?
Pues para un conservador fiscal, libertad
es un estado pequeño con impuestos bajos.
Para un neocon, libertad es luchar contra
los dictadores ¿Entendéis por donde voy?
En esta crisis, el Gobierno no puede solucionar
el problema. El problema es el Gobierno.
Sin embargo hay un problema ¿Cómo es posible
que juntemos en un mismo sitio a gente tan
distinta?
Pensadlo bien, un señor que quiere reducir
el tamaño del estado no se puede llevar muy
bien con otro señor que quiere incrementar
el gasto público para tener un ejército
más grande ¿Verdad?
Pues, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
la clave para crear una identidad polÌtica
que funcione es tener un antagonista. Y en
el caso de Reagan, eso era pan comido.
¡SEÑOR GORBACHOV, DERRIBE EL MURO!
¡Exacto! ¡Los malvados comunistas! Y eso
explica que en los años 80 tengamos tantas
películas donde los comunistas son los malos.
Ahí tenemos "Amanecer Rojo" "Rocky IV" o,
por supuesto, "Top Gun".
Y aquí tengo que hacer un paréntesis: "Top
Gun" es un peliculón. Si tenÈis la oportunidad
de verla no os la perdáis porque merece la
pena.
El caso es que estas pelÌculas, junto con
los discursos de Reagan, sirvió para construir
una nueva hegemonía política.
De hecho, incluso Bill Clinton, que era demócrata,
tuvo que prometer más bajadas de impuestos
para ganar las elecciones.
Sin embargo, como ya sabéis, en los años
90, la Unión Soviética desaparece. Ya no
quedan malvados comunistas contra los que
luchar ¿Y qué pasa cuando te quedas sin
un antagonista que de sentido a tu identidad
política? Pues... ¡Utilizas otro!
Tras el 11 de Septiembre, el presidente George
Bush anunció una nueva batalla entre el bien
y el mal: la lucha contra el yihadismo. El
tío Sam tenÌa un nuevo enemigo.
Recorreremos el mundo con nuestra causa y
no descansaremos, no nos rendiremos y no fracasaremos.
Por supuesto que no estoy diciendo que los
terroristas no sean malos ni muchísimo menos
que los creara Estados Unidos ¿Vale?
Lo que estoy diciendo es que se pueden utilizar
como un elemento retórico para crear una
identidad política.
Y lo han hecho prácticamente todos los grandes
presidentes:
Roosevelt, Reagan y tantos otros políticos
de todo el mundo.
Sin embargo ¿Qué pasa cuando ya no hay Unión
Soviética y Bin Laden ha muerto? Llega el
momento de un nuevo discurso polÌtico. Llega
el momento de:
LA REVOLUCIÓN DE TRUMP
Tras la crisis financiera de 2008, la doctrina
económica hegemónica se pone en cuestión.
De repente, la gente vuelve a no confiar en
el sistema.
La palabra no se difundió entre los medios
de masas. Y la pregunta que surgió era si
esa falta de cobertura mediática era porque
no era noticiable o porque la gente contra
la que protestábamos tenía el control de
casi todos los medios de masas.
Cuando la gente pierde la fe en el algo, se
crea un vacío que alguien puede llenar con
un nuevo discurso. Y aquí es donde entra
el señor Donald Trump.
De nuevo, tenemos a un candidato presidencial
que se alió con toda clase de grupos políticos
y religiosos que se sentían apartados del
mainstream.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el 80% de los
cristianos evangélicos votaron por Trump.
Mucho más que ningún otro grupo religioso.
Sin embargo, los valores evangélicos de familia
y moral son la antítesis de los divorcios
y los escándalos sexuales de Trump.
Y es más, incluso después del escándalo
de Stormy Daniels, que es una ex actriz porno
a la que Trump, supuestamente, pagó para
comprar su silencio, el 78% de los evangélicos
siguen apoyando al presidente.
Es más, algunos líderes evangélicos han
ido más lejos y han llegado a decir cosas
como esta.
SÌ, los conservadores evangélicos le damos
una oportunidad para que se redima. Dijeron,
¡te permitimos que empieces de nuevo y te
damos una segunda oportunidad!
--Tony Perkins hablando en la CNN
¿Pero cómo se explica este fervor? ¡Exacto!
Por el antagonista.
Es decir, para Donald Trump, el enemigo son
los medios tradicionales, los de las fake
news y, por supuesto, lo que el llama ¡EL
PANTANO!
Es decir, todos los polÌticos de Washington.
Y bueno, por supuesto, hay un tercer enemigo
que todos conocéis: los inmigrantes. Más
exactamente, los que estéis viendo este vÌdeo
que habláis español.
En otras palabras, que Trump siempre tiene
el recurso de decir "o yo o ellos". Y, en
ese sentido, su retórica no decepciona.
De los violadores mexicanos a los BAD HOMBRES:
la campaña de Trump en dos momentos.
Y si esta retórica le está funcionando tan
bien a Donald Trump, los demás candidatos
republicanos quieren imitarla.
Todos quieren apelar a esa base de votantes.
Y por eso muchos presumen de ser más trampistas
que el propio Trump
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Pues aquí tenéis
el anuncio de uno de los candidatos a las
primarias republicanas de Virginia.
"El capitan del Pantano, Mitch McConnel ha
creado millones de trabajos para los chinos
y con eso, Mitch se ha hecho rico"
Y la pregunta es ¿Funcionará este cambio
de ideas en los republicanos? Muchos analistas
creen que no. Y, por el momento, el partido
republicano está perdiendo dinero en donaciones.
De hecho, hay 40 candidatos republicanos que
ya han sido superados, en lo que a dinero
respecta, por sus contrincantes demócratas.
Los republicanos están perdiendo en la guerra
de donaciones para las legislativas de 2018
Con gente como Paul Ryan fuera, muchas empresas
han dejado de dar dinero al partido.
Antes, el comité central republicano podía
ayudar a sus candidatos para que financiaran
sus campañas. Ahora, muchos de ellos tendrán
que pagarse los anuncios con su propio bolsillo.
Sin embargo, como siempre decimos en VisualPolitik,
no se pueden hacer predicciones en política.
Así que ahora es vuestro turno ¿Creéis
que los republicanos están perdiendo credibilidad?
¿Creéis que perderán votos frente a los
demócratas? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios.
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos
videos nuevos todas las semanas asÌ que suscribÌos
a VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vÌdeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.